so as a troll on twitter
yeah in the best sense of the word what
do you make uh
of cancel culture i think it's maoism
it's i mean the corporate america has
done a far better job of implementing
maoism than the communist party ever
could you had this
meeting not that long ago from i think
was northwestern university law school
where everyone in the call got up and
said that they were racist i mean this
is something that legally
you should be very averse to saying even
if it were true
and it's this kind of concept of getting
up and confessing your sins before the
collective
is something completely um
are they sorry they admitted this of
themselves yeah they were like because
they're saying because they're white
they're inherently racist so my name is
john i'm a racist might it was this i'm
a racist it was it was uh you hear it
and you're like okay this is looney
tunes
so you're saying that wow that's that
that's so much you took a step further
so
you're saying there's like a a deep
underlying force but
it says cancer culture it's not just
some kind of mob
it's not slim at all it's a
it's a systemic organized movement uh
being used for very nefarious purposes
and to dominate you know an entire
nation
how do we fight it because i sense it
inside
you know i used to defend academia
more because
i still do to some extent it's a nuanced
discussion
because you know like folks like jordan
peterson and
a lot of people that kind of attack
academia they refer
they really are talking about gender
studies at certain departments and
me from mit you know it's the university
of science and engineering and the
the faculty there really don't
think about these issues or haven't
traditionally thought about it's
beginning to even
infiltrate there it's the you know it's
starting to infiltrate engineering and
sciences outside of biology yeah like
let's put biology with the gender
studies like i'm talking about sciences
that really don't have anything to do
with gender
uh it's starting to infiltrate
um and it worries me i don't know
exactly why i like it
i don't know exactly what the negative
effect there
would be except it feels like it's
anti-intellectual
oh yes of course and i'm not sure what
to uh
because on the surface
it feels like a path towards progress
at first when you when i'm like zoomed
out
you know just like like squinting my
eyes the you know
not even in detail looking at things but
when i actually joined the conversation
to like listen in
the conversation on quote-unquote
diversity
it quickly makes me realize that
there's no interest in um
in making a better world no no it's
about domination
it's it's about getting yeah it's a way
for
if you are a lowest status white person
using anti-racism is the only mechanism
you will have to feel superior to
another human being
so it's very useful for them um in terms
of
fighting it uh one of my suggestions has
been to seize all university endowments
which are the crystallization of
privilege
and distribute that money as reparations
so be very effective by turning to
populations against each other
and strongly diminishing the
university's intellectual hegemony
uh the universities are absolutely the
real villains in the picture
thankfully they're also the least
prepared to be aggressed upon
uh and after the government and the
corporate press they are the last leg of
the stool
and they don't know what's coming and
it's gonna get ugly and i cannot wait so
this is where you and i disagree part
one
yeah we disagree in a sense that you
want to dismantle
broken institutions i don't think
they're bro
they're working like by design i think
for over a hundred years
they have been talking about bringing
the next generation of american leaders
which is
code for promulgating an ideology
based on egalitarian principles and
world
domination let me try to express
my lived experience okay sure okay
my experience at mit
is that there's a bunch of
administrators
that are the bureaucracy sure that
[Music]
i can i can say this is the nice thing
about having a podcast i don't give a
damn
is they're pretty useless in fact they
get in the way
but there's faculty there's professors
that aren't incredible they're
incredible human beings
that all they do all day they're
too busy but for the most part what they
do all day
is just like continually pursue
different little
trajectories of curiosities in the in
the various
avenues of science that they work on and
as a side effect of that they mentor
a group of students sometimes a large
group of students and also teach courses
and they're constantly sharing their
passion with others
and my experience is it's just a bunch
of people who are curious about
engineering and math and science
chemistry artificial intelligence
computer science what i'm most familiar
with
and there's never this feeling of
mit being broken somehow like this kind
of
feeling like if i talk to you just now
or like eric weinstein there's a feeling
like
stuff is on fire right there's something
uh but when i'm in in the system
uh especially before the kovid before
this kind of tension
everything was great there was no
discussion of
even diversity all that kind of stuff
the the toxic stuff that we might be
talking about right now
none of that was happening it was a
bunch of people just in love with
cool ideas exploring ideas being curious
and learning and all that kind of stuff
so i don't my my sense of academia
was this is the place where kids in
their 20s 30s and 40s can continue
the playground of science and having fun
it's
if you destroy academia if you destroy
universities like
you're suggesting kind of lessening
their power
you take away the playground from these
kids to to
to play it's going to be hard for you to
tell me that i'm anti-playground
yeah well i guess i'm saying you're on
top certain kinds of playgrounds which
is
yeah the ones that have the broken glass
on the floor yeah i am against those
kinds of playgrounds
no no you're you're you're
yes nope you see that you listen
you wait yeah i i i would say you're
being
the watchful mother who the one kid who
hurt themselves and the glass
one kid it's an intelligent it's
generation after generation i'm not a
watchful mother i'm the guy with the
flamethrower
no i i i understand that
but you're using the one kid who was
always kind of like weird
um gender studies department uh
that that hurt themselves on the glass
as opposed to the people who are like
obviously having fun in the playground
and not
uh playing by the glass the broken glass
and they're just
i mean to me some of the best
innovations in science happen
in universities okay you can't forget
that universities don't have this
liberal
like politics sick literally in
every conversation until this year until
this
this year there's something happening
but uh every conversation i've ever had
nothing to do with politics would never
trump never came up
none of that ever come up nothing like
all this kind of idea that there's
liberal
all that that that's in the humanities
right
yeah but do you think mit massachusetts
into technology might be a little bit of
an outlier yeah that probably is
yeah but i i don't i honestly don't
think
when people criticize academia they're
looking at
uh they're in fact also picking the
outliers
which is they're picking some of the
quote unquote's strongest gender studies
department this is nonsensical when i
was at bucknell
i was a college student we had to take
you know we had a bunch of electives and
i want to take a class on individual
american individualism one of the texts
of the five
that we had to read was birth of a
nation the movie about the clan
so there's no department
where these people are not thorough
going hardcore
ideologues uh this is not a gender
cities that's the humanity fine
all the humanity it's not just gender
studies okay fine i can give you
history english yes all of them every
university as you know
has it mandatory in the curriculum
they have to take a bunch of these
propaganda classes
i look forward to youtube comments
because you're being more eloquent
and you're speaking to the thing that a
lot of people agree with and i'm being
my usual
slow self and people are going to say
not very nice things about me
don't say anything that nice about lex
okay please
let me try to just just shoot up a
school that would be preferable
there he goes again only the teachers go
to the darkest possible place the
sunshine baby schools
that's where everyone goes to be happy
playgrounds there he goes dark
ear just dives right in like it
just go dark and then just comes back
off to the surface
[Laughter]
um you're probably a figment of my
genetician i'm not even having this
podcast well after 18 red bulls i'm
surprised you could see anything
this is like fight club red bull gives
you delirious yeah
uh like i got into it at norton
yesterday on
twitter oh really yeah as he uh like the
rest of the celebrities yeah he's like
oh
this is an existential threat to america
trump's a fascist he's
delegitimizing the oval office i said
what odd endorsement of trump
well you should have went through bad
pit he might have a different opinion
that's spike
reference okay this conversation
is over it's interesting i'd like to
draw a line between science and
engineering
and science not including like the
biological aspect
the the parts of biology that touch
and humanities and biology like i feel
because uh humanities if you just look
at the percentage of universities
it's still a minority percentage and i
would actually draw
different i think they serve very
different purposes
sure and that's actually a broken part
about universities about like why
why is some of the best research in the
world done at universities that doesn't
like there might be a different like mit
it feels weird that a faculty yeah these
are conceptually different things like
we do research and we teach why this the
same yeah
it feels weird but that's just but but
i'm also i'm coming to like the defense
of the engineers that never talk about
i'm not like like my mind isn't i'm not
like deluded or something where i'm i'm
not seeing
the the house on fire i'm just saying i
am seeing the house because i also lived
in harvard square i'm seeing harvard
but even you see the tanks coming
they're coming next they're gonna be so
beautiful i'm gonna it'll be like the
american beauty of the plastic bag i
just won't be able to stop crying
because it'll be so beautiful yeah
thanks i could i can already i can
already see it but the
but the engineering departments were
like i believe
that the elon musks of the world that
the
the like the innovation that will make a
better world is happening
and like let's not burn that down
because it has nothing to do with any
like they're all like sitting quietly in
while like
well the the humanities and all these
kind of diversity programs they're
they're not having any of these
discussions
listen my soviet brother you both know
we both know that ice water runs in our
veins
so if you're calling for mercy that is
not how i'm wired
but i'm not closing the door yeah i'm
actually realizing now
so for for people listening to this i'll
probably prepend this and saying that
i'm even slower than usual i didn't
sleep last night
but i feel i'm actually realizing just
how slow i am
and how much preparation i need to do in
if i would like to defend aspects of
academia
i better come prepared i don't think you
need to defend them i think i'm granting
you your premise freely
no you might be okay i don't think the
the world is that
actually you just defeat your own
argument because you me because it is
not at all
have to be the way that a phenomenal
research institution like mit which no
one disputes
has to also be an educational
establishment these two things are not
at all
uh necessarily interconnected but then
you have to offer a way
to separate correct but like i'm not a
big fan
everybody's different but i'm not a fan
of criticizing institutions without
offering sure a way to change and
especially when i'm like
have ability to change i'd like to yeah
i'd like to offer a path
like what if they were in students they
were all mentor like uh like
meant like um what's the opposite of a
mentor
mentee protege what's the term when you
like when you work
at a place like interns not an intern
something i'm thinking of
but anyway like basically they're
working there instead of going to
college there
it's possible but it's going against
tradition and so you have to build new
institutions and
uh and then have these engineers
building new things that's crazy
yeah these research engineers where
they're gonna be building
things well one of the things because
you're kind of a you know
apprentice that's the way i was looking
at apprentice which is ironic we're
talking about trump and
we couldn't think of the word apprentice
ah very yeah well done
we should both be fired yeah there you
go
these russian jews so quick with their
wit okay
uh but the the thing is you're a fan of
freedom i am
and there's there is uh intellectual
freedom
people this is what i was trying to
articulate i'm failing to articulate
but there truly is complete intellectual
freedom within
universities on topics of science and
engineering
i believe you yeah i agree with you i
don't think it's going to take much
persuasion but i'll give you an example
when that i i'm sure you know more
details about this
than i do when that uh scientist
engineered that probe to land on that
comet
and the articles written because this
hawaiian shirt he was wearing had like
pinup girls on it which i think is
female
student sewed frame or something where
his ex-girlfriend and he had to
apologize
this is what rand was talking about yeah
that the great
accomplishments of men have to say i'm
sorry
to the lowest most despicable disgusting
people
yeah i don't know you know let me bring
this case up because i think about this
uh this might not mean much to you but
it means a lot to a certain
aspect of the computer science community
there's a guy named richard stallman
i don't know if you know who that is
he's the
founder of the free software foundation
he's like a big linux
he's one of the key people in the
history of computer science one of those
open source people right
but he is like i believe he's the one of
the hardcore ones which is like saw
all software should be free okay okay so
very interesting personality
very key person in the new just like
linus torvald
key person so but he also kind of speaks
his mind
okay and on a certain chain of
conversations
at mit that was leaked to the new york
times then was published
led him to be fired or pushed out of mit
recently maybe a year ago and i
it always sat weird with me so what
happened is um
there's a few undergraduate students
that
called marvin minsky not sure if you're
familiar who that is i've heard the name
he's one of the seminal people in
artificial intelligence
they they said that they called him a
rapist
because uh he met with jeffrey epstein
and jeff uh free epstein solicited
uh to these are the best facts known to
me that i'm aware of
that's what was stated on the chain is
he solicited a 17
but it might have been an 18 year old
girl to come up to marvin minsky
and ask him if he wanted to have sex
with her
so jeffrey epstein told the girl yeah
she came up to marvin misky who was at
that time is i think seven years old
and his wife was there too marvin
misky's wife and he said
no or like you know awkwardly yeah so
thank you
no thanks and
that was stated in the email thread
as marvin participating
uh sexual assault and rape of this uh
unwilling sexual assault and it was
called rape
uh of this person right of this
woman that propositioned him and then
richard stallman who's he's kind of
known for this
he's very he's you make fun of me being
a robot but he's kind of like a
debugger he's like well that sentence is
not what you said is not correct
so he like corrected the person uh
basically made it seem like the
the use of the word rape is not correct
because that's not the definition of
rape yeah
and then he was attacked for saying oh
now you're playing with definitions of
rape rape
is rape is the answer right and then
that was leaked in him defending so the
way he was leaked it was
reported as him defending
rape that's the way it was reported and
he was pushed out and he didn't really
give a damn
it's he doesn't seem to make a big deal
out of it he just left he made an
example of him
they made an example and that and
everyone was afraid to defend him
so like there's a bunch of faculty one
dude you're from the soviet union
doesn't this
hit close to home for you i don't know
what to think of it it hits
close to home but it was basically at
least at mit now mit is such a light
place with this it's not common at mit
but it was like
18 19 year old kids undergraduate kids
with this kind of fire
in them there's just very few of them
but they're the ones that raise all this
kind of fuss
and the entirety of the administration
all the faculty are afraid to stand up
to them
it's so interesting to me like i i don't
know if i should be afraid of that
you don't think you should be afraid so
someone who's trying to be specific when
it comes to charges of violent assault
is looking for that clarity can get
their life uh other search warrants
let me give you more context there's a
little bit more context to richard
stallman which is
he was also a rapist no he left out that
part he liked raping people
but he's had a history through his life
uh of you know every once in a while
wearing the hawaiian shirt with
like he would make he's a fat
uh sorry but he's a fat unattractive he
like what trump referred to the the yeah
basement in the basement that's richard
okay i love you this is
is you know he is what he is peop you
know people he like he would eat his own
uh
he would pick skin from his feet and
lectures and just eat it
okay yeah this video is him doing that
i'm not joking he must really behind the
spectrum then
yeah okay yeah and
so and you know uh he i think
this uh and his office he adore
he wrote something like uh uh
like hacker uh plus
plus lover of ladies or something like
that like something kind of
yeah yeah yeah so professional yeah
unprofessional and a little creepy
yeah yeah no that's fair that's yeah so
he was also so they were looking for an
excuse
to get rid of him it sounds like uh no
he was just
who's they the administration yeah
probably
probably a lot of times what people
don't realize and this would be my
defensive cancer culture
a lot of times when someone gets fired
over something like this yeah this isn't
why this is just giving them cover
to get rid of them without getting a
lawsuit yeah but it's still
so i think i guess what i'm trying to
communicate it feels a little weird and
creepy
and he may not be the the best for the
community
but that's not necessarily the message
it's sent to the rest of the community
the message is sent to the rest of the
community that
being clear about words or the usage of
the word rape
is uh like you should call everything
rape that's
that's that's basically the message you
send or you should call that we say rape
rape
it's about submission i think i'm you'd
be very happy to know that there's a lot
of people
and she's very crucified this like betsy
devos the president's department of
education
who are aware of this they are aware
that this completely contradicts due
process
uh they're aware of how a rape
accusation is something not to be taken
seriously
but because it's not to be taken
seriously it has to be also taken
seriously another context
that you know once that word is around a
male this can ruin his entire life
um and that's that that's the sticky
thing of the word
like i like i think about this
a lot that um
like how would i defend it if somebody
like i've never i can honestly say i've
never done
anything close to creepy in my life
like uh with like with women but you
wouldn't know it if you had right
that's the thing a lot of these creepy
guys don't think they're creepy they
think they're being cute
yeah but i'm just telling you even like
fine let's say right let's say i'm not
aware of it but the point
that i am aware of is that somebody
could just completely make something up
correct yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay and like how what a
what would i do no
he denied the charges there's an article
around everything you did supposedly and
it goes
uh mr freeman denied the charges yeah
but what creeps me out
that happened can i interrupt there is
zora neale hurston is one of my favorite
writers she's from the harlem
renaissance
um she wrote their eyes are watching god
a couple other books
she was just an amazing amazing figure
her biography is called
wrapped in rainbows it's just a
masterpiece i like i think i read it one
day can't recommend her enough
fascinating fascinating woman
during the 30s i think it was in 1940
she was out of the country she was
accused of molesting
a teenage boy she wasn't in america
this could be proven so there was is
absolutely false not even a question
she was indicted and she wanted to kill
herself
because she's like people are gonna see
these things
and they're going to think maybe there's
some truth to it maybe it's voluntary
what they're just going to and and you
could understand what should be suicidal
over this
so yeah this is this is something that's
been going on for a long time and in
the fact that it's becoming i do agree
it's important i know a lot of women
who have been sexually assaulted more
than i i'm happy that i know
and if i know that many that means
there's more so i i don't
i think it's it's a good idea that they
feel seen
that they don't feel wounded they don't
feel damaged or they can talk to their
friends
and i'm like man this sucks is happening
to you and and i don't think you're a
i don't think you're asking for it i
think you feel violated i think it's
gross
talk to me like i i do think that that's
important and i also think it's
important though like when things get
kind of in a frenzy
that a lot of people like yeah i also
had something happen and
very quickly the line between he grabbed
my boob and he violently raped me
i don't think these two things are the
same at all i think they're both sexual
assault
but in terms of what someone can deal
with the next day the next month 10
years later
i i don't think there's similar
scenarios
yeah i had juanita broderick on my show
and hearing her talk about
you know her alleged rape by bill
clinton
was very disturbing for me very
disturbing to hear
because it was like half an hour so you
know we think of these things and think
okay
hold her down blah blah yeah and then
it's done half an hour when just even
someone physically holding you down for
half an hour yeah like not even a sexual
assault yeah like
that's traumatic yeah you think am i
gonna your brain's gonna think am i
gonna die
when i zoom out i think the ultimately
this is gonna lead to a better world
like empowering women to speak to those
kinds of experiences
the benefit of it outweighs the
the issue is whenever people are given a
weapon some are going to use it
in nefarious ways and that's the lesson
of history males when males
females whites blacks children adults
when people are given a mechanism to
execute power over others
some are going to use it
you